Okay.
So we've been talking about with the virus,
should we be voting by mail in November?
And Donald Trump has insisted that vote by
mail leads to voter fraud, despite the fact
that he votes by mail.
We've talked about really it's the swing states,
the battlegrounds that are most important
to ensure we can vote by mail so that we don't
hold down Democratic turnout, you know, vote
by mail or not.
California's going to Joe Biden.
Vote by mail or not.
Massachusetts is going to Joe Biden.
But it's those key swing states and even some
battleground or purplish red states where
it's really important that voting by mail
be done.
We know that higher turnout is bad for Republicans
and we have really, really good news.
Texas federal judge has ruled yesterday that
anyone who doesn't want to go out and vote
in person in Texas because they are afraid
of catching Corona virus is entitled to get
an absentee ballot.
Now, this is not as good as vote by mail,
by default.
And I'll explain to you why.
The best scenario would be the state says
every registered voter is going to get an
absentee ballot in the mail, whether they
request one or not.
This is not that you do have to request an
absentee ballot.
But in normal circumstances in Texas, you
have to justify why are you asking for an
absentee ballot?
You have to meet certain criteria.
And it would be a fight over.
Does fear of catching the virus qualify, qualify
you for an absentee ballot?
We've now heard from District Judge Fred Berhe
and Judge Fred Beary says the disability provision
applies to any voter who does not have immunity
to Corona virus and fears they would catch
it at a polling place.
This is a very technical ruling.
Texas has this election code which defines
a disability as a sickness or physical condition
that prevents the voter from appearing at
the polling place on Election Day without
a likelihood of needing personal assistance
or of injuring the voter's health.
The court said fear and anxiety is inextricably
intertwined with voters physical health.
And if you are apprehensive about going to
the vote, going to the in-person ballot box
and catching Corona virus, that is a limit
on your ability to cast a ballot.
So the court decided lack of immunity to the
right to the coronavirus counts as a physical
condition.
You would be entitled to request an absentee
ballot under that pretense.
Now, there's a few caveats here.
You will be able to do this request an absentee
ballot merely for fear of catching corona
virus until this decision goes to trial or
the pandemic goes away.
So I don't know how you define the pandemic
has gone away in November.
If there are fewer cases, if there are fewer
deaths, would that potentially be seen as
there is no more pandemic and voters will
not be allowed to vote for president by mail?
Right now, this will apply to the July elections
in Texas, for example, July 14th.
There's a primary runoff in Texas.
Anybody who is afraid of catching Corona virus
will be able to request an absentee ballot.
November is still more of a question mark.
And, of course, Republicans still don't like
it.
They're going to fight to have this canceled.
By the time of the presidential election,
you've got the Texas attorney general, Ken
Paxton, who says that this could be something
that opens the door to fraud.
And this is the talking point that the right
is choosing to die on.
Essentially, it's the hill they're choosing
to die on.
Voting by mail should be available to anybody
who wants it.
Period.
The entire state of Oregon has had vote by
mail for 20 years, more than 20 years.
They've put it in place in 1998.
They had a ballot initiative.
It passed about 70 to 30.
And it's funny how you look at the arguments
in 1998 against vote 97, 98 against vote by
mail in Oregon.
And it's the exact same thing that Republicans
are saying right now.
You go back and look at the comments in the
90s in Oregon from people like state Rep.
Lynn Snodgrass or anti-tax activist Bill Sizemore
in the 90s.
They were saying we can't have vote by mail
in Oregon.
It'll invite election fraud.
It'll allow people to pressure others about
how they vote.
Now, the truth is, vote by mail is very popular
in Oregon.
Eighty one percent support in 2003.
Really hard to get 80 percent support for
anything right now.
But more importantly, 30 percent of respondents
in Oregon in 2003 said they vote more often
since vote by mail was an active enacted.
That is what Republicans don't want.
That is what scares the hell out of Trump
about vote by mail for November of twenty
twenty.
Let's put a vote by mail in place in more
places.
And let's also understand that we should really
focus in on the swing states.
Now, on the fraud question, vote by mail does
not lead to more fraud.
Check out the numbers that we have.
Over the last 20 years, 250 million votes
have been cast by mail nationally.
Twelve hundred cases of voter fraud in all
forms have been identified.
Eleven hundred resulting in criminal convictions.
So what do we know over the last 20 years?
We have had almost no actual voter fraud.
It almost always eleven hundred out of twelve
hundred times.
It led to a criminal conviction, meaning you
are very likely to get punished and be found
guilty if you participate in voter fraud.
And when you look at how many of those were
with absentee ballots, it's only 200 of the
12 hundred.
OK, so of the almost non-existent voter fraud.
Twelve hundred cases, one sixth were with
absentee ballots.
That means seven or eight cases per year nationally.
OK.
Seven or eight?
Not seven or eight percent.
Not point seven point eight percent.
Seven or eight cases nationally per year of.
Absentee ballot related voter fraud, which
is only one sixth of the total.
Most of them are in-person.
No methodology is perfect.
Fraud is not an issue with vote by mail.
Do not let them trick you.
Make them provide the evidence of it because
there is no evidence.
The numbers are overwhelming